Игорь Агафонов: и можем, в принципе, проговорить про ваш сервис, про наш сервис и найти точки соприкосновения. Не знаю, посмотрели, не посмотрели, чем занимаемся. Я могу так коротко рассказать. Вы,
Игорь Агафонов: в принципе, тоже поделитесь. Потом расскажу про ту программу, которую Олег вам, видимо, рассказывал, партнерскую, как мы в целом можем с вами посотрудничать.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Расскажите. Меня Репресс так вкратце накидал то, что есть.
Игорь Агафонов: Смотрите, наш основной клиент – это крупный селлер, либо бренд. Вот есть два портрета. Если говорим про селлера, какая задача? Мы видим наших коллег -репрайсеров, которые занимаются
Игорь Агафонов: в принципе плюс -минус тем же, только в меньших объемах. Если, условно говоря, у нас заходит клиент и платит за лицензию, то мы дополнительные, скажем так, деньги не берем за объем.
Игорь Агафонов: И можно запускать хоть каждую минуту фильтры. Ну, понятное дело, что кому -то нужно в час, кому -то там 15 минут, кому -то там раз в несколько часов запускать различные фильтры. Но,
Игорь Агафонов: по сути, мы делаем и репрайсинг, и смотрим цены в разных регионах, и под это, под все делаем фильтры по ценам, подтягиваем цены, следим за ценами конкурентам. Ну, в общем, там у нас
Игорь Агафонов: сейчас больше 60 автоматизаций постоянно, там раз в неделю у нас 2 -3 какие -нибудь автоматизации еще выходят. Вот, например, из последнего, когда сертификаты ввели обязательные, да,
Игорь Агафонов: у нас там один клиент недавно подключился и такой, боже мой, что бы мы без вас сделали? Мы начали сертификаты заводить, там, 2000 сертификатов заводили двумя людьми почти месяц. С помощью
Игорь Агафонов: вашей системы, они дня за три, наверное, справились, у них 440 тысяч SKU и сколько -то тысяч сертификатов. Вот такие автоматизации у нас. Соответственно, по репрайсингу, если смотреть,
Игорь Агафонов: например, средний селлер, ну средний это для нас средний селлер, у которого 40 -50 тысяч SKU, у него, если он пойдет, условно говоря, к нашим коллегам, будет выходить в 2 -3 раза дороже.
Игорь Агафонов: только репрайсинг. А у нас, например, к этому репрайсингу исследование за ценой... Да, вы что -то хотели сказать?
Ранис (Sirena ai): Да, вы немножко скачете от теми к теме. Ну, в общем, да, смотрите.
Игорь Агафонов: У нас, да, у нас,
Ранис (Sirena ai): короче...
Игорь Агафонов: Да, задайте вопрос. В общем, давайте задайте вопрос лучше.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Ну, вопрос. Скорее всего, сейчас просто покажите функционал сервиса, что умеет делать. Я примерно понимаю, что у вас сервис, который объединяет разные функции, но зато очень под большие
Ранис (Sirena ai): объемы заказчиков. мой сервис наоборот под малый бизнес, мы наоборот работаем с небольшими, у нас нет возможности большие обрабатывать данные, у нас есть возможность, но она функционально
Ранис (Sirena ai): не так показывает, мы не заточены под структуру, у нас есть крупные клиенты, у которых тысячи, десятки тысяч, а то есть сотни тысяч SKU, и ваш сервис им будет интересен и полезен, мы
Ранис (Sirena ai): все нужно понять функционал, что умеет, что делает, какие решения может принимать или не принимать, дальше по ценообразованию просто пройдемся немножко, и мне потом понадобится, ну,
Ранис (Sirena ai): какой -нибудь, не знаю, презентация, ну, функции того, что может сделать сервис, скорее всего, чтобы я мог это просто клиент наш перекинуть, и они такие, о, прикольно, хотим потестить,
Ранис (Sirena ai): вот, типа, вот так нам нужно это действие, хорошо? Да, хорошо,
Игорь Агафонов: сейчас чуть -чуть шума будет
Игорь Агафонов: на заднем плане, ну, в общем, если говорить так, то вот демонстрационный стенд, есть ссылка demo .sellhub .ru, я вам все скину. Соответственно, что у нас основное, кроме того, что вы,
Игорь Агафонов: например, подключаете свои товары, загружаете с разных площадок, Ozone, Valberis, Яндекс .Маркет в основном пользуются. Первое, что я хочу сразу сказать, что это основные площадки,
Игорь Агафонов: которыми пользуются наши клиенты, но...
Ранис (Sirena ai): Так, уточню. Вопрос,
Ранис (Sirena ai): добавляем через API, Интеграция через API проходит, правильно понимаю?
Игорь Агафонов: Да, конечно. Мы, по сути, являемся хабом, через который мы подключаемся к клиенту, а дальше уже сами распределяем все карточки, все характеристики и так далее. То есть, по сути, вот
Игорь Агафонов: так же контекстно накинул у больших селлеров, иногда возникают такие проблемы, что, например, по API есть лимиты. То есть, они к API сами подключаются через 1С, через какую -нибудь
Игорь Агафонов: еще систему репрайсеров, еще через разные системы и упираются в лимиты. Вот мы как раз в лимиты не упираемся, можно подключиться чисто к нам, и наша внутренняя опишка уже дальше дергает
Игорь Агафонов: все цены, распределяет и меняет, и всю информацию аналитику тоже выгружает клиенту. То есть мы, получается, таким связующим звеном между клиентом и всеми маркетплейсами по опишке.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Смотрите, важная часть, у крупных клиентов, например, моих, у них есть структура, связанная с безопасностью. Если что -то делать для них, то это какой -то закрытый контур нужно для
Ранис (Sirena ai): них закрывать. Если такая возможность есть, это первое. Точного вопроса возникнет. Вы говорите, что у вас есть свой аппи, который скачивает без лимитов. Это на примере какого сервиса?
Ранис (Sirena ai): Например, ВБ. У вас как бы лимиты ВБ перепрямляет? Вы авторизованный сервис, поэтому вы можете скачать без лимитов.
Игорь Агафонов: Ну, смотрите, я так скажу, что, естественно, лимиты ВВ есть. Я к чему говорю? Что, например, они могут подключаться через несколько своих сервисов и дергать информацию разными сервисами.
Игорь Агафонов: То есть у нас есть клиент, например, у которого, в общем, близко к 100 тысячам из КЮ. Данные находятся в
Ранис (Sirena ai): 1С, и вы данные тащите не напрямую с ВВ, а можете с 1С подтянуть тоже.
Игорь Агафонов: Конечно. И мэчить, если какое -то изменение произошло, у нас локально база хранится, если что -то произошло, мы не тратим токены на то, чтобы весь ассортимент и все обновлять, мы тратим
Игорь Агафонов: токены только на то, что обновилось внутри себя и отправляем это уже на площадку. То есть мы, получается, сравниваем свежесть данных внутри себя.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Так, это хорошо. Окей, 1С, мой склад, что еще возникает дополнительная интеграция, которая есть у клиентов?
Игорь Агафонов: Retail CRM тоже частая обычная интеграция. Сейчас Яндекс Кит подключили, вот тоже у клиента была необходимость к Яндекс Киту. И вот смотрите по поводу того, какие интеграции, еще раз
Игорь Агафонов: хочу обратить внимание, что если даже какой -то интеграции нет, мы там неделя -две ее делаем. Вот был клиент, которому нужно было выйти на n -видео ну хорошо видео так и видео то есть
Игорь Агафонов: в принципе любой marketplace который необходим либо любая интеграция с любым сервисом мы это делаем достаточно быстро
Ранис (Sirena ai): окей смотрите вот с такой проблем сталкивался сейчас мы подключаем озон тоже для нас сервиса и у нас такие проблемы иногда короче данные которые мы получаем по api они не сходят с данным
Ранис (Sirena ai): то происходит на кабинете данных много разных разносторонних Типа продажи можно с разных мест вытаскивать. Вы как этот вопрос решаете?
Игорь Агафонов: Давайте разберем какой -нибудь из ваших сценариев, и я расскажу, как мы это решаем. Где нестыковка? В чем, например, может быть?
Ранис (Sirena ai): У меня нестыковки бывают у заказчиков. То, что данные, которые мы в серии показываем по API, они не сходятся с данными, которые есть в кабинете. Объем продаж с объемом продаж, который
Ранис (Sirena ai): есть в кабинете.
Ранис (Sirena ai): При этом,
Ранис (Sirena ai): наш основной клиент смотрит главный дашборд, и там чуть -чуть финансовый отчет, скорее всего.
Игорь Агафонов: И
Ранис (Sirena ai): есть случаи, когда данные сильно отличаются. У вас такие случаи бывают? Возникают такие проблемы у вас? Если да, то как вы ее решили?
Игорь Агафонов: Ну, смотрите, по поводу данных о продажах. Естественно, мы тянем первично данные из кабинета. То есть у нас есть как бы точка правды, которая находится в кабинете селлера. Если в кабинете
Игорь Агафонов: селера данные эти есть, то я не понимаю, как могут они отличаться от тех данных, которые, условно говоря, у него в 1С или где он ведет.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Расскажу про нашу боль. Может быть, эту тему решили, просто поняли, как это делается. Мы по API, например, на примере продаж, продаж может тащиться с нескольких вариантов API. с еженедельного
Ранис (Sirena ai): финансового отчета, еженедельного финансового отчета, если сверху делать, с маркетингового отчета, с воронки продаж, с прогноза остатков. В смысле остатков можно тоже продажи, по сути,
Ранис (Sirena ai): вытаскивать. Куча продаж. И они отличаются друг от друга.
Игорь Агафонов: Смотрите, у нас, естественно, какие -то вопросы такие тоже возникали.
Игорь Агафонов: Сейчас у нас есть свой внутренний BI -сервис. Мы его особо не пиарим, не рассказываем о том, что он у нас есть. Но, по сути, мы тоже мультиканально все это подгружаем к себе внутри.
Игорь Агафонов: И отчет, который формируется, по сути, он у нас является точкой правды внутри системы на основании данных, которые есть в кабинетах продавцов. Поэтому то, что, например, может не сходиться
Игорь Агафонов: в 1С, в ритейл, в CRM, в мой склад и других системах, это уже такие редкие случаи. Тут надо садиться и разбираться, где, условно говоря, произошла нестыковка. Может быть, подтянули
Игорь Агафонов: отчеты, там возвраты какие -то. Может быть,
Игорь Агафонов: подтянули, не знаю. Ну, в общем, разные ситуации есть. То есть нужно конкретно в каком -то сценарии сесть и посмотреть, где произошло разногласие.
Игорь Агафонов: Ну, я не могу просто на ваших данных... Да, да, да. Сейчас, секундочку. То есть на ваших данных это нужно проверять, смотреть просто у клиента, где у него произошел вот этот... Я понимаю,
Игорь Агафонов: просто
Ранис (Sirena ai): про свои случаи, которые у нас были, мы по интеграциям. И такие случаи у меня у коллег, которые занимаются сервисом аналитиками, много делают.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Поэтому, думаю, решили запрос или нет. Если решили, то это прекрасно. Особенно для крупных клиентов это супер важно, потому что они не будут там копаться. А если найдут случайно какую
Ранис (Sirena ai): -то нестыковку цифр, и на весь объем, то это будут сильные вопросы к тому, что у нас не стыкуется что -то. Окей. Окей, мы загружаем данные, можно грузить, получается, по IP стандартно
Ранис (Sirena ai): все, что можно вытащить из по IP. Если у вас есть Ozone, VB, Aiense Market, можно дополнительные сделать, это круто. Потому что, например, для градиента, там золотого яблока точно им
Ранис (Sirena ai): нужно будет. Они точно продают на Littuale, вроде тоже, что у Marketplace, я не помню. У них очень большое количество брендов. Еще для них очень важная штука.
Ранис (Sirena ai): У них еще есть дополнительно
Ранис (Sirena ai): дистрибуция розницы.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Магазины, офлайны и все остальное. Они тоже все данные собирают. И тоже нужно единый контроль всех цен. Чтобы не было такого, что на VB у тебя дешевле, чем, к примеру, стоит в гоше
Ранис (Sirena ai): утрированно. Такую, по нему, тоже можно штука что -то доинтегрировать при необходимости клиента. Отлично. Смотрите, по поводу вот этого сценария,
Игорь Агафонов: Как у нас здесь организовано, просто расскажу. Смотрите, есть фильтры по поводу, например, там РРЦ. Если у розницы стоит одна цена, а на маркетплейсе другая, естественно, владелец бренда
Игорь Агафонов: либо владелец магазина может говорить о том, что, ребята, почему там у какого -то селлера, либо еще у кого -то, и там сейчас вообще к кабинету бренда больше относятся, Но в целом и
Игорь Агафонов: у селлеров тоже, у которых есть розница, есть такие вопросы. Смотрите, как мы решаем этот вопрос. Есть выгрузка, например, по RRC -цене. Мы этот прайс подгружаем и ставится на данную
Игорь Агафонов: категорию, на данные товары. Цена, которая не может уйти ниже рекомендованной цены. Но с учетом того, что, например, тот же ВБ любит баловаться с инвестом и начинает делать скидку,
Игорь Агафонов: и таким образом может произойти разная цена, например, в каком -нибудь регионе, просто он сайинвест поставил, и там стоило 1000 рублей, а стало стоить 800. Вроде бы селлер получает
Игорь Агафонов: столько же, но как бы цена ниже. Мы эти вещи тоже видим, и у нас есть фильтры сайинвеста, когда, например, цена есть РРЦ, но она не может пойти ниже вот этой, даже если произойдет сайинвест.
Игорь Агафонов: То есть мы в этот момент делаем проверку цены. Если мы видим, что произошло снижение из -за площадки, мы эту цену повышаем. И таким образом мы можем контролировать цену не ниже той,
Игорь Агафонов: которая есть, например, в рознице. То есть таким образом мы и дистрибьюцию, и онлайн держим в едином ценовом диапазоне.
Игорь Агафонов: Вплоть до количества регионов, которые…
Ранис (Sirena ai): Уточню по поводу терминологии. Фильтры, понимаете, вы называете это ограничный метрик, который мы ставим в рамках работы репрайсера.
Игорь Агафонов: Да, да, да. То есть автоматизация. Давайте вот так. Просто фильтр такая.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Ну, это некие правила, по которым надо работать. Правило такое, работает так.
Игорь Агафонов: Да,
Ранис (Sirena ai): да. Окей. Так. Это хорошо. С репрайсером обсудил. Ценообразование, изменение цен. Окей.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Как часто мы можем парсить фильтры, это наша задача, как хотим уже час, 15 минут, 2 часа, день. До минуты,
Игорь Агафонов: да.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Окей, до минуты. За API, например, сейчас в Аббрис, API платный, платите заказчик сам или платите вы как сервис?
Игорь Агафонов: Смотрите, сейчас в нашу подписку входит полностью все под ключ, то есть дополнительных никаких платежей нет.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Все, я понял. Так, хорошо.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Так, кончик. Окей, движемся дальше. Получается, у нас по цене мы отработали. По остаткам планирования... Поставок, распределение поставок, если товара много.
Игорь Агафонов: Тоже есть такая автоматизация, будем говорить тогда, не фильтр, а автоматизация. Соответственно, какие есть по остаткам и по складам автоматизации? Если можно
Ранис (Sirena ai): показать просто в интерфейсе, показать это, если можно сказать, в демо.
Игорь Агафонов: Слушайте, в демо, скорее всего, здесь мы не ввели, Это здесь несколько таких презентационных. Я вам, может быть, позже скриншоты просто пришлю, как это делается, либо сделаю скринкаст.
Игорь Агафонов: Да, скриншоты
Ранис (Sirena ai): вполне будут.
Игорь Агафонов: В общем, если коротко, то, например, есть задача, вот есть ФБС, ФБО.
Игорь Агафонов: Какие здесь есть фильтры? Первое, например, продавать с ФБО пока не закончится, только потом подключать с ФБС. Либо, например, если несколько там маркетплейсов, как распределять товар,
Игорь Агафонов: то есть на этот маркетплейс столько -то, на этот маркетплейс столько -то процентов, на этот столько -то. Как торговать со складов, там, например, 40 на 60 процентов, то есть часть со
Игорь Агафонов: собственного склада, часть с склада маркетплейса и так далее. То есть также вот я говорю, что мы пока эту историю не сильно пушим, наш BI внутренний. Также у нас есть вот планирование
Игорь Агафонов: поставок, потому что, по сути, мы можем…
Ранис (Sirena ai): Следующий вопрос у меня был по планированию.
Игорь Агафонов: Да, смотрите, мы можем отдавать информацию по оборачиваемости, И таким образом планирование поставок может быть основано как раз на том, насколько быстро мы продаем, вернее, селя наша
Игорь Агафонов: продает и насколько быстро у них происходит оборачиваемость. Это тоже я вам чуть позже могу присылать всю эту информацию подробнее и показать, как это работает. То есть, по сути, у
Игорь Агафонов: нас, кроме того, что мы условный репрайсер и хаб опишек, мы также такой внутренний BI -аналитик, который подсказывает, что продается, за сколько продается, какой процент вообще продаж
Игорь Агафонов: товаров от общего количества и так далее. То есть мы, в принципе, это тоже подсказываем, помогаем.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Это хорошо. Так, ну, понимаю, интеграция моего склада у вас есть, ритейл -серами, потому что вы можете смотреть, какие остатки у вас на ФБС, грубо говоря, на фулфилмингах хранятся,
Ранис (Sirena ai): и можем спокойно эти данные использовать для ФБС, грубо говоря.
Игорь Агафонов: Да, мы можем это использовать, и у нас это уже, в принципе, есть.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Окей. Так, ну, честный знак, сертификация, GTIN, вот это все остальное.
Игорь Агафонов: Вот я вам рассказывал, что сертификаты мы подгружаем при необходимости, сами честным знаком не занимаемся, мы только являемся условно -говорясь связующим звеном между вами и между маркетплейсом.
Игорь Агафонов: То есть честный знак получить – это задача ваша, задача селера.
Игорь Агафонов: промаркировать. Нет,
Ранис (Sirena ai): получить, да, интеграции нет, у вас нет ли самим знаков, чтобы я прям маркировку мог через ваш сервис закидывать?
Игорь Агафонов: Слушайте, я этот момент уточню, потому что
Игорь Агафонов: вопрос такого особо не было, но давайте я уточню и скажу вам потом чуть позже.
Игорь Агафонов: Потому что по честному знаку вроде бы должно быть, да.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Там не сложная механика, там у них достаточно добротная API, надо поебаться, короче, но
Ранис (Sirena ai): интеграция такая полезная, короче.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Особенно связано с производством и в России, и в Китае, и в Киргизии, и где -то еще из Казахстана товар, где -то еще контрактный производство идет для косметики, это супер важная штука.
Ранис (Sirena ai): У них с этим чесноком такая
Ранис (Sirena ai): война постоянно. Это должно быть, потому что у нас
Игорь Агафонов: по сути запчасти, автозапчасти, шины, диски, это все тоже маркировано. Я вам еще чуть позже отвечу, как это происходит.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Скорее всего, ваша компания, наверное, на ранней стадии это сама как -то решает, скорее всего, а вам просто не требуется. Но было прикольно, если бы ваш сервис тоже мог эту тему решить.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Это как бы кайфовая штука будет.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Так, окей.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Сертификаты окей, ценообразование окей.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Вот вы говорите планирование по поставкам. А планирование по прибыли, планирование по оборачиваемости, такие системы можно учитывать в репрессинге?
Игорь Агафонов: Ну,
Ранис (Sirena ai): за счет оборачиваемости, предположим, товара. Смотрите,
Игорь Агафонов: вот задача посчитать, условно говоря, сколько вы можете зарабатывать, это уже на вашей стороне. Мы можем показать вам данные о том, какая у вас маржинальность, и в принципе настроить
Игорь Агафонов: автоматизацию, чтобы маржинальность единицы товара была там не ниже, чем столько -то. То есть мы такой фильтр настроить можем.
Игорь Агафонов: То есть товар дальше продается в виде оборачиваемости. Соответственно, на основании данных, которые... То есть мы не увеличиваем продажи, мы не занимаемся увеличением продаж и так далее.
Игорь Агафонов: Мы даем аналитику, на основании которой вы принимаете решение. Например, ага, вот эта группа товаров, и в разрезе вот этих товаров, вот данные вот эти товары, например, имеют вот такую
Игорь Агафонов: маржинальность и вот такой -то оборот. Соответственно, их надо поставлять больше, к примеру, если они заканчиваются чаще или у них более короткий срок.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Я про то, что можно же ценой управлять и оборачиваемостью. Я могу делать 20 % за месяц, я могу делать 1 % в день и при этом зарабатывать 30 % если мне товар запас позволяет. Это уже
Ранис (Sirena ai): ваша стратегия. Да,
Игорь Агафонов: я понимаю. Можно ли здесь вашу тему протегию настроить? Я про это.
Игорь Агафонов: Смотрите, можно, если вы видите, например, что у вас есть высокая оборачиваемость И вы можете снизить цену и за счет этого ее увеличить Потому что позволяет маржинальность То, естественно,
Игорь Агафонов: вы настраиваете такой фильтр и делаете То есть у нас как раз -таки некоторые клиенты за счет этого увеличивают, ну, растут То есть они как раз видят, что есть высокая оборачиваемость,
Игорь Агафонов: есть там маржинальность Они могут себе там склад большой по такой -то группе товаров. То есть это, смотрите, такой фильтр настроить можно, это все в ваших руках. То есть мы отдаем данные,
Игорь Агафонов: на основании которых вы принимаете решение.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Ну, я про то, что решение, да, можно автоматизировать, ну, не что я не ручку пошел это править, короче, а что в вашей сервисе, я поставил пару галочек, и система пошла это сделала.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Я про это.
Игорь Агафонов: Такого пока нет, но я говорю, что в принципе звучит как легкая доработка.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Ну, я про то же говорю, что не сложная механика, просто... Так, окей. По работе с рекламой. Что -нибудь есть у вас в вашем сервисе?
Игорь Агафонов: Рекламой мы не занимаемся. То есть, в принципе, для крупного селлера больше головных болей с тем, чтобы все правильно выгружалось, все быстро обновлялось. И держались цены. Опять же,
Игорь Агафонов: если вы про золотое яблоко говорите, про разные такие крупные компании. Есть ритейл, есть... В общем, есть офлайн, есть онлайн. И по факту офлайн часто жалуется на онлайн, что там цены
Игорь Агафонов: в онлайне более низкие. И мы понимаем, что зачастую это даже не в селере дело, а в маркетплейсе. И вот мы как раз помогаем держать цены чуть ли не там до региона. Хотите, Ростовскую
Игорь Агафонов: область поставили дополнительно поднимать, хотите там Екатеринбург и Сыдловскую область, то есть вот мы в этом сильны.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Хорошо, я понял. Отлично. Так, ну
Ранис (Sirena ai): вопросов у меня пока нету.
Ранис (Sirena ai): В общем,
Ранис (Sirena ai): прощите скрины, потому что есть, есть презентация, тоже классно будет. Я с этого сформирую оффер, пришлю к клиенту, я думаю, что назначу вам встречу на следующую неделю. Я думаю, ребятам
Ранис (Sirena ai): будет интересно.
Игорь Агафонов: Ну, я тогда вам еще Еще про партнерку нашу расскажу, потому что, кроме того, что это может быть интересно им, это же должно быть интересно вам, смотрите, какая у нас партнерская программа.
Игорь Агафонов: У нас есть два тарифа. Первый тариф – это селлер, второй тариф – это бренд. Я, кстати, сейчас посмотрю, привезу.
Игорь Агафонов: Что входит в селлер и в бренд? Значит, селлеры обычно, ну, понятное дело, что это те, кто продают бренд, это тот, кто, например, продает через селлера. И, по сути, задачи немножко разные.
Игорь Агафонов: У селлера задача, так сказать, продавать у самого бренда, следить за тем, как продают селлеры на его электронных площадках. Значит, по условиям мы платим 30 % от покупки лицензии за
Игорь Агафонов: первый месяц У нас селлер стоит 200 тысяч, бренд стоит 300 тысяч Соответственно, при покупке вы получаете 60 тысяч бонусов При покупке бренда вы получаете 90 тысяч Есть также годовые
Игорь Агафонов: тарифы То есть некоторые, например, проходят месяц -два с нами, потом оплачивают год. Некоторые сразу заходят на год, когда особенно по рекомендации понимают свою выгоду. Тогда за селлера
Игорь Агафонов: получаете 200 тысяч, за бренд получаете лицензию 300 тысяч. Я, опять же, могу все это показать. Могу вам скинуть презентацию такую общую, обзорную. Вы познакомитесь для себя. Слушайте,
Ранис (Sirena ai): я уточню какие вопросы. Смотрите, партнерская... Программа мне интересна, мне интересны рекурятные платежи.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Я хотел, чтобы я завезу вам клиента, пускай сумма будет меньше, но просто я могу действительно крупных ребят провести, и не свершенные запчастей, а из косметики, из обуви, из строимого
Ранис (Sirena ai): материала. Там, блин,
Ранис (Sirena ai): вы ему уже нужны.
Игорь Агафонов: Мы можем это обсудить, да, действительно, тогда, если так посудить, процент будет меньше, скорее всего, мы говорим в размере, возможно, 5 -7%. В зависимости от крупности и понятности
Игорь Агафонов: клиента.
Игорь Агафонов: В общем, это можно обсудить. И смотрите, у нас просто были такие запросы. Рекуррентные платежи. Тоже есть партнер, который крупных клиентов приводит. У нас платежи рекуррентные в течение
Игорь Агафонов: года. Мы с ним согласовали. Вот смотрите, например, в течение первого месяца он так получает 30%, а в течение года он получает 60%. Мы ему согласовали по 5 % в месяц платеж.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Да, возможно, но мне интересна такая штука, чтобы, как вариант, предположим, больше, чем год, но если я буду просто работать, ну, грубо говоря, не серия, привел, вообще там 3 месяца,
Ранис (Sirena ai): типа 3 года ничего не делаю. А если я постоянно привожу клиентов, то пролонгирование, ротация моих клиентов. Также я просто с этими клиентами консалтингом. Это мои клиенты, я им консалтинг
Ранис (Sirena ai): веду по разным направлениям. Где -то маркетплей занимаемся, где -то занимаемся. У многих этих ребят высокий уровень лояльности на чек, на заход. И продажей я буду заниматься, скорее
Ранис (Sirena ai): всего, даже в том числе. Вам демонстрацию продукта надо показывать. Там все хорошо. получается.
Игорь Агафонов: Давайте, Ранис, мы это обсудим в команде, потому что прецеденты я говорю, чтобы были, а вот чтобы прям долгого сопровождения, мы давайте это проговорим, и я вам вернусь с ответом.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Я просто понимаю, в чем суть вашего продукта, и как бы мне очень сильно отвлекается, потому что мы эти штуки автоматизируем блин, через хрен полон колено, короче. У нас и Дипа, Ракета,
Ранис (Sirena ai): X -Fay, там по финансам, короче, куча сервисов, которые все делают. Мы хотим все это объединить в единое, но в единое мы работаем только больше с малым, а вот для крупных ребят нужны
Ранис (Sirena ai): такие ребята, как вы.
Игорь Агафонов: Да, мы здесь. Вот, и по сути, если у вас еще что -то есть, что вы не спросили, можете спросить.
Игорь Агафонов: Я ваши вопросы записал.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Так,
Ранис (Sirena ai): ну, по кастомным разработкам мы понимаем, что все хорошо, вы можете дополнительно, а понимаю, кастомные разработки это отдельно оплачиваются.
Игорь Агафонов: Да, смотрите, расскажу как есть, так как я так понимаю, вам интересно долго сотрудничать. Если заходит новый клиент и у него кастомная какая -нибудь разработка, ну вот, например, в
Игорь Агафонов: мой склад какие -то интеграции, которые нужно сделать, которых у нас нет, мы такое сделаем бесплатно, то есть какие -то первые базовые мы можем сделать. Если клиент уже есть платящий,
Игорь Агафонов: он приходит и говорит, так, у нас есть желание пойти, не знаю, новый маркетплейс какой -нибудь открылся, и мы хотим подключиться в маркетплейс. Тогда это кастомная разработка, которая
Игорь Агафонов: оплачивается. В среднем 100 -200 тысяч может быть доработка, но тогда и понятное дело, что клиенту это нужно, то есть проверяется деньгами. То есть бывает такое, уже проходили через
Игорь Агафонов: такое, что дайте нам вот такой маркетплейс, дали, а что не пользуетесь? Да мы что -то подумали, передумали, а мы разработчикам платим. Поэтому какие -то прям кастомные разработки, которые
Игорь Агафонов: на старте нужны клиенту нашему, мы можем в рабочем порядке за счет своих собственных средств в первый месяц сделать. Какие -то в процессе работы мы, естественно... Выставляем счет за
Игорь Агафонов: это.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Это нормальная практика, все хорошо. Я это прекрасно понимаю, мы делаем то же самое.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Так, вопросы еще. С НДС работаете, кстати, вы как компания? С НДС работаем. Как софт.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Отлично. Отлично, оттуда вообще все будет прекрасно.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Так,
Ранис (Sirena ai): если можно, карты предприятия тоже можете прислать? В любом случае, вас будет служба безопасности проверять 100%, все это компании, такие штуки проходят. Карточку пришлю, да. Если пришлете,
Ранис (Sirena ai): Карточка, блядь. Ну, если это, ну, я думаю, это не конфиденциальная информация, а ребята. А она открыта на сайте
Игорь Агафонов: висит. Мы же в российской области в списке.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Ну,
Ранис (Sirena ai): все, отлично. Так, а вы аккредитованы по, да, сказали?
Игорь Агафонов: Да, да, да, да, да. Мы в аккредитованные, то есть, и эта информация тоже на сайте есть, то есть, можно прям посмотреть, зайти. Ну, карточку я пришлю, если что, да. Ну,
Ранис (Sirena ai): сильно, сильно не влазил. А мне, кстати, сайт Олег тоже не прислал. Или вы мне сайт прислали?
Игорь Агафонов: Давайте сейчас пришлю
Игорь Агафонов: sellhub .ru
Ранис (Sirena ai): Да, вы можете видеть сайт, в сайте написано Я просто, если у вас сайт не читал Мне не Олег писал, мне не вы не писали, поэтому Я так думаю, я смотрел, вроде бы сайт не смотрел
Игорь Агафонов: А, ну хорошо, в общем Sellhub .ru Много сайта смотрю
Игорь Агафонов: Да, в общем, на сайте тоже есть У нас задержка
Ранис (Sirena ai): примерно 5 секунд
Игорь Агафонов: В общем, на сайте Есть вся плюс -минус Информация, плюс я пришлю карточку что зафиксировали, пришлю информацию по честному знаку,
Игорь Агафонов: ну и, в общем -то, презентации тоже пришлю, партнерский кабинет тоже пришлю, условия по вам обсужу с командой. Так, и еще, вы работаете с Авито, да? С Авито тоже работаем, да.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Что Авитосервис делает? Тоже ценно -ценно управляет, получается? Ну,
Игорь Агафонов: смотрите, в Авито на самом деле у нас там не сильно большие интеграции, мы туда больше вот как хаб действительно работаем, То есть с Авито там загрузка -выгрузка товаров и, соответственно,
Игорь Агафонов: цен и характеристик. То есть вот так. То есть так, как на ВБ, например, или на Азоне следование за ценами, мы такое не делаем. То есть там больше по Авито как репрайсер.
Игорь Агафонов: Репрайсер и загрузка -выгрузка товаров.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Загрузка -выгрузка через XML, да, в Грузии получается? Да, да, да. формируете для закона.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Ну, тоже полезная штука. Прислить тоже по виду. У меня тоже есть большой клиент по запчастям, по виду занимается кузовным ремонтом.
Игорь Агафонов: Хорошо.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Так, сейчас посмотрю, что -то ваш сайт. The Market, Emix. С Emix тоже работаете, получается. Да. Вот как раз клиенты по
Игорь Агафонов: запчастям попросили.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Еще одна запчастная большая компания есть, называется Emix. И еще один здесь большой тоже игрок. Блин, запчасти попал.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Ладно, вспомнил, напишу, он тоже спрошу по поводу этого возможности интеграции.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Так, ну,
Ранис (Sirena ai): вроде все, пока вопросов пока нет.
Игорь Агафонов: Все хорошо, я тогда сейчас пришлю три презы. Первая презентация для селлера, что мы делаем. Вторая презентация для бренда, что мы делаем. И третья – это партнерка стандартная. Ну, понятно,
Игорь Агафонов: я услышал вас про, скажем так, про другие немножко условия, которые вы хотите. Но мы это все обсудим тогда.
Ранис (Sirena ai): Супер, прекрасно. Все, тогда хорошего дня вам.
Игорь Агафонов: Да, спасибо, тоже рад знакомству, уронить тогда на связи. До свидания.